come sarà la mamma di bianca senta io
non ho capito che mia figlia iniziando
aveva tutti i dieci adesso sei sentito
lo può spettare ha preso 4 certo che me
la detto mia figlia mi dici tutto adesso
di abbastanza male sacmi atg al
capodanno le maldive stanchezza del suo
bungalow studiare stessa che mia figlia
ogni giorno è un'attività est o
scolastica è la più brava del soccorso
di pole dance ha idea di cosa voglia
dire conciliare studio e sport a questa
mia figlia paese da me e intelligente
bella forse per questo che la presa di
mira o forse in vita il nostro titolo
nobiliare
non deve essere facile per una come lei
aver interesse una bolla della famiglia
da acquaviva d'aragona come non è nella
sua classe
così rimane la cosa possiede
oddio mi scusi devo scusarmi levi
dovevano tele nostro castello o position
titolo nobiliare pavani se le va bene
cagione meglio contestati vederci scusi
core